[Music]
oh
i failed the gun is in my hand sorry
i'll make it next time you almost got me
didn't you boy
we had a lot of fun today i could take
her again next week
[Music]
[Music]
shadow
[Music]
so
what do you want you're coming with us
kid
it's not me you need to be scared of
little girl but the man standing next to
you
now i don't know who he is but i know
who he's not
should i tell her you
he's gonna come for me now
you're gonna see what i see
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no
i can't see you
[Music]
my grandmother was right the boogeyman
was real
it's over we can't hurt anyone ever
again
no one told you told me what
somebody in there
[Music]
[Music]
should not have to keep running evil
dies tonight
[Music]
i'm not just gonna sit and watch another
innocent person die if you track
michael's victims
that's a straight line to michael's
childhood home
what do we do we fight let's hunt him
down
michael myers is flesh and blood
but a man couldn't have survived that
fire
the more he kills the more he transcends
he's the essence of evil
do it you want your mask
come and get it i'm coming for you
michael
[Music]
this is where it all began they stole
your candy man
lone character he walk around handing
out candy to the neighborhood kids
one day a couple of kids get razor
blades in their candy
police come around that's when i saw the
true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him killed him
right there on the spot a couple weeks
later
more razor blades and more candy he'd
been innocent
so he's real candy man ain't a he
candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
god
right here in this neighborhood the
legend started
uh-huh and the legend is if we say his
name
five times while looking in the mirror
we could summon him
summon the candy man hell no
[Music]
candy man anthony no
i don't want to get creeped out in my
new apartment before bed okay
black people don't need to be summoning
no i dare you don't say that say he's
like
you better not do that last one you want
to be a part of the story right no
say his name candy man
[Music]
anthony anthony
anthony are you okay
the hell is going on this neighborhood
is haunted
i think i made a mistake
[Applause]
you should say candyman say his name
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
i think it's about time they accept the
existence of the devil
you okay there jesus
i think i hurt someone in 1981
arne johnson pled not guilty
[Music]
we think this family was cursed
by reason of demonic possession i am not
going before a grand jury and saying he
was possessed by
[Music]
demons
[Music]
color me your color darling
come up off your color chalk
[Music]
i know
[Music]
i know who you are
the ride all right
when you're alone and life is making you
lonely you can always go
downtown when you've got troubles all
the noise in the hurry seems to help
i know downtown
just listen to the music of the traffic
in the city
[Music]
linger on the sidewalks where the neon
signs are pretty
how can you lose
[Music]
the lights are much brighter there
you can forget all your
your cares troubles go downtown
things will be gray when you're
downtown
[Music]
everyone's waiting for you
[Music]
do you believe in ghosts
[Music]
downtown
we've studied outer space more than the
earth
what happened
where are the others
everything is just like in a regular
shaft
but later on you'll see what we actually
created here
this form of life is unknown to science
it's the end of the human race
[Music]
[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here
[Music]
play me
[Music]
hello detective banks do you know where
your officers are
jigsaw well i thought that jigsaw killer
was dead
he is
find him there hours not days how can i
catch this guy
if there's nobody on the i can fuss you
can't do this alone
whoever did this has another motive
something personal
was the last time you saw your father
jigsaw copycat it's gonna go sideways
[Music]
fast
i need everyone on this case
it could be anywhere he could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Applause]
[Music]
hello detective banks when was the last
time
you saw your father
the annual purge will conclude in three
two one
thank you for your participation
we survived all police and emergency
services have been reinstated
all crime including murder is now
illegal come on let's get to work
one night only rest of the year is
peaceful
[Music]
help me help me
the purge is over please
no it ain't this is insane
nobody hear the sirens there's no crime
anymore
anything else you rich can't hide behind
your steel walls no more
powerless how does that feel is the real
purge the forever purge
hurry up they're coming
come on follow me there's nowhere safe
to go
no way to get help oh my god
we gotta find another way to get out of
here
[Music]
this country's gonna collapse
mexico was opening its borders for the
next six hours
we're in this together
[Music]
speak
does this translate
so you too need a little help
i will give you the best possible chance
of getting pregnant
how does that sound that sounds great
am i gonna be one of those women who has
it all my career or my kids
my old man by my side who are you going
old
you are 100 pregnant
[Music]
welcome to the family
[Applause]
how are you a little crazy i am
seeing things honey me too i'm having
the wildest mommy brain lately
i don't i don't think it's mommy brain
i think doctrinal did something
i think there you know
in on what
gives me a bad feeling i want to see
someone
more natural
there's a lot of voodoo out there we
just want to make sure that you get the
best possible care
confront whatever it is that's blocking
you
from you i'm not crazy they're trying to
make me think i'm crazy
[Music]
hey this pregnancy [ __ ] is no joke
right okay it's really scary
brilliant
happy anniversary pumpkin things have
been bad between us
and i'm sorry i don't know when surprise
isn't gonna fix
everything i love you with all of my
heart
until death do us part
i'm impressed you made it this far
there's one final surprise
happy anniversary pumpkin
we're not leaving until we open that
safe 200 grand
in rocks we split the diamonds let's go
two people knew the combination to that
state the guy who hired us
and the girl she could be miles away by
now
she's still in the house
[Music]
i wanted used to get hurt he wants you
to scream
please
such a perfect couple
i'm gonna cut myself free of you if it's
the last thing i do
[Music]
it wasn't your fault
[Music]
i had his hand
your eyes open you might see a whale or
a shark
okay we're going down
what the hell was that we're sitting
fast
we're floating around in this piece of
plastic junk
and if the shark is still out there i'd
rate our chances at all surviving
less than five percent
so do you think it's gone it's still out
there
that's close
we can't give up we can still survive
if we do nothing we're done
where is it it's got to be out there
somewhere
the sickness hangs over the city like
putrid fog
bodies are piled higher than narrow
streets
it's as if the day of judgment has
finally arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll give you some advice leave tone
while you can
i saw it the other day she was acting
bloody peculiar
there's only one thing that can explain
it she made a pact with the devil
know where to run witch
what's that they'll try to break you
like they did to the rest of us
fear not my child salvation is at hand
there's something wicked at work in that
place
[Music]
just the devil insider
all my will is greater than yours
nobody's safe
you were lucky to get out of those
escape rooms alive i need to know that
the criminals who killed the four people
in front of me
are held accountable hiding in plain
sight in the middle of manhattan
we need to stop them i'm in
i know this is a lot to ask but thank
you for coming with me
hey what the hell is going
mino's escape on no no no what's
happening again
you guys have played the game before so
what is this
like a tournament of champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
this ad yourself is missing an e so
maybe we pull the corresponding handles
with a missing letter
yes
come on
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time you
gotta try something right
yes there's a special reason each of us
survived
i can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
take a picture it'll last longer get
some clues this looks just like the
lighthouse on the postcard
it's over i'm done running we can beat
them at their own game
what makes you think they're gonna let
you walk away free again
[Music]
we're gonna get it i'm not playing your
game
not now not ever
we need it we made it
i don't understand we're still in the
game
[Music]
i saw something out there
[Music]
someone
[Music]
the largest organism on the planet lives
right here
growing waiting
and it's ready to spread
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my husband took the boat out on the lake
he took a
handgun that i didn't even know that we
owned and
[Music]
did he leave a note he did
you were right there is
nothing nothing is after you
you're safe now
you said you were safe safe for one
[Music]
and then over here we have uh the
husband
you know that we're paying people to do
that right you don't have to do it all
yourself
owen
[Music]
i didn't think we had secrets everybody
has secrets
it's our house but backwards
what the hell was he doing
you were right you were right
there is nothing
you're safe now
our father who art in heaven hallowed be
thy name
may your kingdom come may your will be
done
[Music]
amen
[Music]
father daniel i would like you to meet
father peter costello
father daniel comes highly recommended
as our newest and finest recruiter
what are the archbishops tell you about
me you're the best sexer says there is
what he didn't tell you was that they
can teach you the prayers but that's not
what separates us from your average
priest
you need to be willing to put yourself
at risk
change those clothes you look like a
priest
an exorcist doesn't hide from evil he
runs toward it
you know what i witnessed it's the
epitome of darkness
this young boy needs help i saw this on
the news this morning
he murdered his family so what are you
waiting for
i know you
father dave
or my dream
that demon was the strongest i've ever
seen
[Music]
evil is clever he needs an
army and an army needs soldiers
so they can grow more and more powerful
never scored a cell
well
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you